okay so you guys are gonna get a kick
out of this right this is this is crazy
I'm sitting in an air B&B in Lexington
right now with Mariah she's actually my
sister's house but we're here for the
week of Christmas and and I've never
done an Airbnb so I was like let's do
one of these unless you see what it's
like it's cool okay so apparently I
totally ruined everybody's ability to
get the single issues for Adam the
legend the blue marvel right like you
can get in trade but the single issues
are ridiculously expensive so I go into
one of the local comic book stores here
that I haven't been in in like two years
right so I go in a local comic book
stores and I was like yeah do you guys
have copies of Adam the legend the blue
Marvel and he was like he sorta laughter
he's like no man and I was like why he's
like dude you like the sixth person that
asked me today if we have it and I was
just like what and so like I just need
to know who I was because I was like I
was like what's the deal with that like
I thought you guys would have that he's
like no he was like it was a series that
Marvel didn't print super heavily at the
time like when it first came out and so
like it just kind of sat around cuz not
a lot of people knew about it and then
this comic book youtuber comes to
explain to the video series on it and
like everybody over the course of the
last year has been coming in and trying
to get it because everybody thinks he's
gonna be the next character that's
introduced in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe
and I was like okay well making you guys
or it he was like dude like the issue
number ones depending on the quality
range anywhere between three hundred
dollars to a thousand dollars like it's
expensive as hell and that's that's just
the issue number one that's not the
other other five issues that go along
with it and I was like damn man so like
I kind of ruined everybody's ability to
get a copy of Adam Eliza no blue Marvel
and the single issues I'm pretty sure
you can get the trades on Amazon pretty
cheap I don't know I haven't looked but
that is kind of struck me as funny so
I'm sorry guys
I've totally screwed that up for
everybody I didn't mean to I didn't mean
to but apparently I guess I haven't made
the characters super popular I don't
know that's just one comic book shop
owners they probably got a whole bunch
of explanations as to why but like if
I'm the reason why it's impossible to
get your hands on an Adam the legend to
bloom one more comic book I'm not really
upset about that's kind of awesome that
like me and other comment bigger
youtubers are driving up sales for comic
books right so I guess that flies in the
face of like everybody who says we're
ruining the industry but but yeah
that's pretty cool like that that's
that's pretty awesome anyway I figured
I'd share that with you guys and yeah
you know I think I'm gonna give away
some trades for the atom for atom
legends boom ah well I think I'm gonna
give away some trades on patreon so if
you guys aren't patrons head over to
patreon.com/scishow
how much disclaim you get ad free videos
over there by the way and yeah I will
catch you all later